what happens when going back to work
becomes a source of motivation after an
accident or illness
Stefano lost both forearms to a machine
in an accident at work after a
revolutionary double hand transplant
he's learning to use his new limbs
Parliament's calling for europe-wide
solutions to tackle long term sickness
absence and to provide greater support
for people to remain in or return to the
job market MEP proposals would include
helping to make workplaces more
adaptable to people with disabilities
and chronic conditions individual
reintegration programs with support from
counselors or social workers or
psychological support after a burnout or
stress-related illness
and older people who choose to remain in
the workforce rather than retire should
also benefit from support like
vocational training Parliament believes
this growing pool of potential employees
should be seen as an opportunity not
only for the physical and mental
well-being of individuals but for the
good of society in general
[Music]